The mayor of Uvalde, Texas,
announced recently that Robb
Elementary School would be
demolished.
"You can never ask a child to go
back or a teacher to go back in
that school ever",
he said.
What happened in Uvalde was a
gruesome tragedy that exposes
some of American culture's worst
pathologies a fixation
on guns and violence,
untreated mental illness,
large swaths of alienated
and angry young men, incompetent
and unaccountable police.
The media went looking for
solutions.
What if we could keep guns out of
the wrong hands or get the right
people medicated?
Or reform the police?
Or fix what's plaguing angry
young men? All legitimate questions.
But what the media rarely asks is,
are we part of the problem?
A growing body of research
says, yes.
This is learned behavior.
And the media coverage is is leading
more people to learn it and to
copy it.
University of Alabama criminologist
Adam Lankford has studied mass
killers for more than a decade and
concluded, along with many other
scholars, that the way the media
covers mass shootings
incentivizes more mass shootings,
and for the killers to create as
high a body count as possible.
He says fame seeking is a motivation
he's consistently observed across
the majority of mass shooters.
The more victims they kill,
the more fame and attention they
get. We've seen that in the
United States, mass shootings have
become more deadly over time.
And it seems to be directly related
to this.
"There seems to be too much demand
for fame in America", Lankford
writes.
And not enough supply.
We see people posting
videos and and outrageous
statements to get attention.
Mass killings is just the most
extreme version of this, where
people aren't just being offensive
or outrageous to get attention.
And they know this works.
Essentially, this is guaranteeing
them fame and celebrity
status.
One of Lankford studies found that
winning a Super Bowl or Academy
Award garnered less media attention
than committing a high profile mass
killing. Perpetrators get pictured
more on front pages than their
individual victims.
And there's a strong correlation
between the number of victims harmed
in these attacks and the amount of
media attention that perpetrators
receive.
So the media is rewarding this.
And, of course, you know, you can
think about, well, why did they do
that?
I think part of it is, is clickbait.
Essentially, what was some of
the most striking evidence to you
that seeking this fame
and going out in a blaze of glory
was really a common motivation
for mass killers.
The Columbine killers wanted to kill
250 people.
That was their goal.
And although they didn't kill as
many victims as they wanted, they
were talking about how movies would
be made about them.
And they were talking about whether
Steven Spielberg or Quentin
Tarantino would be directing.
Right. Certainly movies were made
about them and they've received a
tremendous amount of attention.
And then we know from connecting
the dots that subsequent
shooters have considered the
Columbine killers to be role models.
Of all the incidents that have
happened that inspired
copycats, Columbine seems to
be the one that stands out as
inspiring the most.
You know, also, I guess if we just
think about the historical context,
you know, 24-seven cable
news was kind of
coming into the forefront
at that point. Right?
So there was a lot of desire
to fill time on
TV by covering current events.
And this was a big one.
Right. But, you know, some studies
suggest that like Columbine received
more attention than like major
U.S. military
events and incursions and
things like that. In other words,
that it received an outsized
amount of attention, given that,
as tragic as it was, you know, it
was relatively limited in terms
of the actual number of victims
killed.
And yet, you know, it's its
actual influence has
been inflated and
and prompted by
the media coverage it received.
Langford's 2019 study found
that at least 16 mass shooters
since Columbine have voiced fame
or notoriety as a motive,
and that the fame seekers tend to
have more than double the body
counts, and many articulated
a desire to surpass past
records.
Many of these mass shooters
don't particularly have any sort of
empathy for their victims, and
they're willing to kill their youth.
They're using their victims as
the means to an end.
And that end is fame
and what they would consider glory.
In 2007, Virginia Tech was
the deadliest mass shooting in U.S.
history. And then in 2016,
the Orlando Pulse nightclub shooting
was the deadliest mass shooting in
U.S. history.
And then a year later, in 2017,
the Las Vegas mass shooting was the
deadliest mass shooting in U.S.
history. Right.
We see these kind of terrible
records being set and reset.
And since Columbine,
all eight of the most
lethal or deadliest mass shootings
have been committed by fame seekers.
It's not just Langford saying this.
A 2017 FBI report says
the dominance of 24-seven media
coverage perpetuates the mass
shooting phenomenon and allows
it to grow and evolve and
suggests news media should refrain
from naming the assailants, from
posting their photographs and videos
and communications, and
from publishing detailed
investigations into their lives and
motives. More than 100 researchers
have joined Langford in signing on
to the Don't Name Them Movement
petition, which asks major
media to adopt new norms for
covering mass killings.
Nobody looks in the face of
the most recent mass shooter and
thinks, Oh, now that I
see what he looks like,
I know how to stop these attacks
more effectively.
Sometimes you have a trial
of a mass shooter, you know, a year
later or sentencing period.
And the pictures and
the names are continued to be used
in the coverage when it's no longer
news.
And so I guess I just point to
kind of the thoughtless use of this
information as clickbait.
I just want to be perfectly clear
that from my understanding of
this letter, that you and your.
Colleagues have put out this call to
action.
You're not calling for any sort of
government intervention in terms of
limiting the right of the
media to publish certain
information. This is all norms
and voluntary action, correct?
Right. In other words, I guess we'd
like to encourage you or if it came
down to it, to shame these companies
into acting in a more
socially responsible way that
protects public health.
We're not saying the government
should formally
restrict this information.
Again, I don't think that's
possible. It can lead to
even more mistrust of government.
Look, the people who work for
for media companies, they don't
want to see more people die.
I think they just need to look a
little more closely at the evidence
and and take a look in the mirror
and say, can I make this problem
slightly less serious based on my
own actions?
There's a couple objections that
come to mind for me that I'd
be curious to hear your answer to.
One is that when
I think of the idea of media
curtailing coverage in certain ways,
like not showing people's faces
or their names or going into
their motivations and manifestos,
one is that the information
will get out there on less
reputable sites.
We're in the digital age now, so,
you know, now more than ever, the
information is going to get out
there. You're generating maybe
something approximating a black
market in information.
And that's where disinformation
thrives and perhaps even creates
even more of a taboo,
maybe in some deranged way, even
more a more romantic aura around
these guys.
How can we avoid that?
So I think it's a it's a good point.
In other words, like, I'm under no
kind of delusion
that this information won't
get out in some ways.
I guess what I would just say is the
degree of attention
matters. In other words, it's not
binary. It's not either that
information is completely
kept silent or it's totally
out there. Less coverage is
meaningful, right?
We're not going to cut out all
coverage.
But if we don't give these mass
shooters, Super Bowl type like
advertising for
the terrible things they do
and just kind of have it more
restrained.
That in itself would would make
a difference.
Suppressing any kind of information
could lead us to missing some
kind of important pattern or clue
that could prevent the next one
of these from happening.
Like what if there was a series
of connected ideological
killings that we don't fully
understand because there's kind of
like a media blackout
on covering
the full extent of what's going
on here.
Don't limit any information
about warning signs or backgrounds.
That's all very important
and needs to be discussed and needs
to be analyzed carefully.
Just, you know, keep in mind
that the face itself is not useful.
And there are other ways to refer to
someone and
have everybody know who you're
talking about based on the date of
the event and the location of the
event, without really giving that
person's name the
attention that he craved
as part of his decision to attack.
Is there a sense that this is really
something that is going
to take years, maybe
decades, to see some
sort of effect reversing?
Well, I guess it just depends on how
dramatic the change or
the intervention is.
Right. So if
major media organizations
change their processes in subtle
ways and don't tell anyone about
it, then I don't expect
mass shooters to to change
what they're doing at all.
Right. The best thing would be
if major media companies came out
and said, we're no longer going to
publish the names or faces
of mass shooters.
And then the next time a mass
shooting happens, which it will,
they stuck to that.
Right. That would send a powerful
message. And
and the mass shooters, I think,
would start to learn that they can't
be rewarded in the way they were in
the past.
Just searching some of
the recent killers names
on some of the major media sites
will show you that these measures
are far from being the norm today.
But have you seen any signs
of progress or reason to hope
for improvement in the recent
in recent years?
Or are you pessimistic
about any near-term change?
It's a great question.
One of the things I've seen, which
was a little disturbing is
some members of the media kind of
patting themselves on the back as if
mission accomplished.
We've already changed how the media
covers mass shootings and
and I don't think that's the case.
One thing that has been a change is
I think you've seen more attention
given to the victims of mass
shootings, but
that doesn't fix the problem.
In other words, like doing something
good on the one hand doesn't
mean that the other things you're
doing that are dangerous or any less
dangerous.
There are more media companies than
ever before, and there's kind of
more competition for media companies
for eyeballs.
Right. It's not like we just have
three news stations and a
couple of major newspapers or things
like that.
And unfortunately, like the pressure
felt by members of the media
because of the competition that
they're involved in, sometimes seems
to be leading them to
resist change, even if there's lots
of evidence suggesting it would be
the right thing to do.
Many of us know the names of the
Columbine shooters and the
names of many other killers.
How many victims names do you
remember?
Or how about this name?
Elijah Deacon.
Do you know Elijah Deacon?
I'm about to show you some of his
work, and I want to give you fair
warning.
Skip ahead about 15 seconds
if you don't want to see something
quite gory and disturbing.
Okay, ready?
That's what's left of a murderer
whom Dicken gunned down in a
shopping mall after he'd killed
three innocents.
Many more people would have died if
Dickens hadn't intervened, said the
local police chief.
If more angry young men thinking
about doing something horrible saw
pictures like that instead of mug
shots or old school photos,
would they maybe think twice before
going on shooting sprees?
Demolishing the school building
where this tragedy occurred won't
do anything to stop it from
happening again.
But burying the legacies of the men
responsible for such atrocities
just might help.